- I'd like to be on a
show with Blake Shelton.
- [Kelly] Are you, you would, oh my God.
- That would be, I, is he as-
- [Kelly] Actually, that
would be, you would love him,
and it would be very funny,
what would kind of both of your mouths,
like, about each other.
Yes. He's very fun to work with.
- Oh, he is.
- Do you wanna know why?
It's because probably how
much y'all loved working
this is why I love working, he and John,
it's really fun to work with people
that can put their ego aside
and just have a good time,
and, like, go in on each
other and, you know,
you love each other at the end
of the day and you're good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's why it's so fun.
- Oh, that's great, that's good to hear.
- [Kelly] Yeah. And
there's nothing like it
'cause I think it feels like sometimes
in this industry people can have doors up,
and they're afraid to look silly
or afraid of what people
are not being credible
or afraid of all these things,
- Right, right.
- and that fear I think really, you know,
stifles creativity and
stifles a good time.
- [Jane] Exactly, I agree, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, he was on "Reba"
when I did her show.
- I know, I know.
I know, I knew that.
- He was really adorable.
- [Kelly] I know.
- So, you worked with him.
- Yeah, I did.
- You never told me that.
- Well, I don't tell you everything.
(audience laughing)
- Wait a damn minute.
I am really disappointed.
Like, you know,
I have not worn heels in two years.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's the one
positive about the pandemic.
- Much less, strap-on heels,
so when we were headed here, I said,
"Lily, I've got gotta hold
on to you when I come on."
See, I tell you everything.
- [Kelly] I said-
- I'm never gonna wear heels again.
- [Kelly] And you leave out
run-ins with Blake Shelton.